so thanks to Lana analytics and Jared
for inviting me here
I actually attribute a lot of my being
here and thank you and my career path to
him so thanks thanks buddy
all right intro who the heck am I so my
name is URI I work at glossier it's a 4
year old e-commerce beauty company that
emphasizes choice peer-to-peer
connections and facilitates glowy and
dewy skin and so basically our what
we're known for is a skin first makeup
second that's our mantra so you can
basically say that we're a full-stack
skin care company with some makeup
products on the side but it turns out
this is actually a really good metaphor
for our work as data scientists so we
have a lot of excitement about neural
networks lipstick and cheek color but
not so much missing data logging or
sunscreen so to think about it another
way
we use hierarchical models and random
forests and a smoky eye on some
occasions but a smoky eye isn't really
appropriate for every occasion
so what really matters is the fact that
you're using eye cream as part of your
daily routine
so there are base factors that you need
to incorporate into your routines
whether it's skin care or your data
science work so my career basically I
started a Facebook I worked on the
marketing science team for about two
years running a lot of controlled
experiments with advertisers to measure
the effectiveness of Facebook as an
advertising medium and some creative
multivariate tests and then I moved over
to Hillary for America where I managed
the digital analytics team until I
didn't and
and now I'm about six months into
glossier and so something that we say in
the data science community a lot I found
in my short career in data science is
that about one to five percent of our
work is about creating models cross
validating model selection the sexy
stuff and the 95 to 99 percent of the
work is data cleaning munging sourcing
data and that's not so much the stuff we
get excited about so it was actually
great to hear the talk before this about
scaling and growing a data science group
but let's talk about how to develop a
good culture as you develop that group
and grow it and I'm the only person who
uses are at my company so it's really
wonderful to be around all of you guys
and to nerd out about our so just
basically this talk is a reminder that
there are some foundational principles
that we all should talk a bit more about
share tips about and so hopefully this
this fosters communication about these
sorts of topics especially during the
the breakout sessions so there are four
things that I want to talk about to
categorize the 95 to 99 percent of the
work that we do into four admittedly
very broad categories first sourcing
data to hypothesis testing third
documentation and then the fourth is
sharing our work with our stakeholders
but it's a little more fun to use an R
code metaphor within those examples so
this is a simple boring function I often
use to count the amount of missing data
in my data sets a few questions that you
typically ask yourself when you're
working with a new data set is how much
missing data do I have do empty strings
count is there some context that I'm
missing around persistently missing data
that I might need to take into account
in terms of technical limitations or
their ad blockers that are preventing me
from getting the context from my client
site events is their imbalance data but
this is a metaphor so metaphorically
what I mean by this is let's use an
example I bet a lot of us have
experience working in digital ad
measurement where a lot of there's a ton
of data there
impressions clicks time stamps and for
better or worse a lot of the value of
those digital advertising campaigns are
based on whether a click occurred or not
but a question that we should ask
ourselves is does our key outcome
actually translate well to our
independent variable and so in this case
is a click what an advertiser actually
wants to measure and optimize for kind
of know the thing that they want to
measure is the value of a customer lead
is whether a customer purchased or not
really hard to measure let alone
attribute clicks painfully easy to do
both of those things and so something
which we should be admitting to
ourselves and owning up to ourselves
especially when we're forming inferences
off of our analyses and also sharing it
with our stakeholders who will
inevitably translate our inferences to
others is be really careful about how
that translation is being done you can
probably see too many really bad
examples of that across the internet of
how badly data was translated into
inferences but it's not just about
translations it's just about it's also
about what data set are you working with
so you should be skeptical also about
where your data set came from in this
past year
five-thirty wrote an article very honest
article about how they had an
inappropriate use of broadband data
encourage you to all read that
and sometimes increasingly the
conversation these days is actually
around the opposite of missing data so I
don't know how many of you have heard of
gdpr but it's basically data privacy
guidelines there's one fan over there
data privacy guidelines that were
introduced by the European Commission
these these sorts of laws we as data
scientists absolutely have to be at the
forefront of these conversations we have
to talk to the lawyers we have to talk
to our companies about what the impact
is going to be on our work and what the
implications are for our ability to
serve our customers and our stakeholder
as well so money tip 1 be honest with
yourselves and your stakeholders in
order to build your political capital if
you're using a proxy for your ideal
measurement outcome be upfront with
yourself and your stakeholders and be
careful of what you say because I'm sure
many of us have war stories about how
there were mistranslations between what
you were trying to communicate and how
that was taken a step further by others
and at glossier admittedly we haven't
totally solved the problem but a few
strides that we've made is we actually
now own the tech specs for the events
that happen on our website so that's one
piece of success and for the most part
I've seen at other companies the tech
team owns that we have to own those
things so making strides so the next
thing I want to talk about is this
sequel statement or also a bad joke but
that's subjective so we I don't know how
your workflows are like but mine are
often write a buncha sequel and then
write a bunch of are so the metaphor
being that there's a lot of pre-work
that we have to do before we do the work
so it goes to say the four before
beginning hypothesis testing we have to
think about the business question we
have to think about the theory so we
have to define our expectations ahead of
time
and before answering questions which are
often causal we have to ground those in
theory the sounds are really simple but
it it's hard to do in practice with a
lot of pressure especially from
demanding stakeholders and especially
with these days big data being promoted
as a panacea our stakeholders and
sometimes us care a little bit less
about the theory sometimes but we should
Google big data hubris and you'll find a
lot of really bad examples of how that
was taken too far and so some practical
advice here is actually from one of my
favorite TV shows Silicon Valley
so before often the main developer
characters actually talked about how to
tackle a problem they go to the
whiteboard they they think about the
problem they they lay out their
expectations they draw diagrams often to
hilarious effect and I feel like we
should do that too so before so if a
stakeholder comes to you and asks you a
question like does this correlate with
this thing back them up get them to the
business question and I want them to
expect us to not immediately go to a
sequel table or our bi instance and
start pulling things around
we should they should expect us to look
outside the window or start drawing
things or doing like Beautiful Mind
stuff so let's encourage that from them
in any case I want us all to be beta
better
theoretical data practitioners and first
stakeholders to expect that from us so
money tip 2 to start with pen and paper
get stakeholders to ask you their
business questions not data questions
it's your responsibility to translate
those into data questions a great
example earlier this week I saw Supreme
Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert
and he randomly asked her whether a hot
dog was a sandwich she turned it back
around on him and she asked him define a
sandwich what is the sandwich to you and
then they want to make the foregone
conclusion that a hot dog of course is a
sandwich
so side note here some people don't
agree with me so I note here is that
something else I'd like to lay down
before actually beginning my work is
commenting so before I start and really
dive into an analysis I'll write a bunch
of comments laying out the the plan for
my analysis first load the data set then
check for missing data blah blah blah
and something I really like about that
is that encourages me to not get bogged
down into a data rabbit hole I'm sure
that's a very familiar problem for many
of us and then it keeps you focused on
your North Star so next thing
[Music]
documentation so speaking of comments
documentation this is obviously a very
bad comment duh you say I am reading in
a dataset you are right this is a bad
comment what I should have said was give
some context around the data set note
some quarks maybe a link to the github
sequel so comments are favors to our
future selves we this is something that
we have to do not just for ourselves but
also for obviously reproducibility or
sharing our datasets with colleagues who
might then go on to use our own code if
you're changing assumptions especially
with regards to cleaning your data set
it's easier to debug it's easy to
identify where you made that assumption
it's a friendly step up for other
are literate colleagues who are moving
your code if you're lucky enough to have
our literate colleagues but I don't just
mean literally I mean metaphorically so
we all know that there is a replication
crisis going on in the scientific
community right now pea hacking
so-called no promotion of negative
results big data obviously is a problem
in terms of wanting to make datasets
public certainly doesn't make it easier
to do that
but there are a few things that that
we've instituted at glossier that helped
us be responsible to our future selves
and our colleagues and our future
colleagues too so we've established a
framework for sharing our work it's sort
of a five-part template for how we share
our work first a mechanism for open
commentary and feedback we use a lot of
tools at glossier but Google Drive is
probably my favorite we have an
executive summary details about the
methodology and why we chose that caveat
section is really important and then
also in appendix where we can share our
links to sequel github contextual
visualizations and it's really hard to
do this at a fast-moving startup
glossier just closed on over 50 million
Series C funding round so people have
very high expectations of us rightly so
and it's hard to step back and and move
slowly and document all of our
experiments and our analyses but in the
long run this this ultimately becomes
that much more worth it especially when
you're scaling a team and when you're
scaling a company who can quickly grow
into silos so we need the the purpose of
doing these the this sort of framework
whenever you're executing an analysis it
just helps everybody else run that much
so money tip 3 be selfish to your future
selves write good comments document your
work and be open to critical feedback it
makes your work that much better and
something that we do a glossier is
before introducing our analysis or the
outcome of an experiment with a broader
group with the broader company we share
with a smaller group of stakeholders
with trusted stakeholders who we know
are really critical so next the last
thing of course I had a GE plot
reference in here
I loved the power of a good simple
visualization
it's a metaphor for the strategy step
where we take in before we share our
work and we contextualize it for our
audience this can be the hardest part of
our work because we're dealing with
things like the dunning-kruger effect
politics again demanding stakeholders
who who have misconceptions or very
baked preconceptions in mind so if you
want to be effective if you want your
analysis and your work to go far and
have the biggest impact you need to
think about your audience and where
they're coming from and how to present
to them so I like to game theory it a
little bit and there there's some really
interesting research science research
out there about how you how you can
communicate with those types of people
so I encourage you to to find that
yourself but going back to the previous
thing that I said it's if this all
starts with a critical feedback period
where you're gaining different
perspectives about how people might
interpret your results and taking those
into account and doing that all
beforehand before you share that more
widely and obviously that helps you
better incorporate different
perspectives and be really critical
about yourself and expect and and grow
that within your culture of encouraging
critical feedback so money tip for game
theory your result sharing process
take your stakeholders preconceptions /
misconceptions into mind diplomatic
Elise steer them towards what you're
trying to actually communicate them and
it ends up in the long run
building more trust building more
political capital which I think we need
in the community these days and don't
bury the lede be upfront about what
you're trying to say be upfront about
your inferences tap on a great simple
visualization on top of it and that
helps you get your work that much
farther and that's it so I hope this
this provides some fodder for a good
good conversation during the breakout
talk and I'd love to hear your tips
about how you guys share your work with
your stakeholders and how you document
and how you also balance the the trouble
between taking a lot of time to document
your work and share your work and moving
quickly
[Applause]